another survival zombie multiplayer game
on Steam early access with
microtransactions hey ah you know what
I'm sorry it might actually be good I
don't want to be the guy who just judged
[ __ ] I want to be respectful and I want
to give this game the best chance it
could possibly deserve let's do this
was I wrong no yes yes I was wrong
how would good in me it actually works
are you we're gonna [ __ ] wait gonna
play these [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm gonna get my 15 pounds of fun if the
last thing I'll ever do it's one instead
of zombies has dinosaurs where have I
heard that before
it seems pretty original let's play it
there are no games running no one is
playing this game alright well so far
great great I just wanted to have fun on
a Saturday play some games
for [ __ ] sake you piece of [ __ ] how
do they get away with this
oh now it works no nevermind
I love video game you this is oh my god
you just had to spit in my face
lucky for us there's another dinosaur
survival game actually there's about 500
of them
dad dammit uh is it how what is there
any hope at all
holy [ __ ] are you kidding me I actually
get to play no no way
okay what do we get I can't roll in this
game though it's I'm a little
disappointed to be honest j2t teacher
you are great at dancing Wow Wow we're
never made a defender the hug you don't
know me Papa give up anything to rip the
heart for me even wonder me together for
defeat little [ __ ] because we should
because I'm PETA defeated a few years
well they're truly a miracle
Wow astounding architecture amazing
graphics gameplay to die for
two hours now
how is ah let's do nether it's it's
actually pretty cool and I played it
before and I enjoyed it so I don't
remember my password all right well how
do I retrieve it all right well let's
not play nether then just want to play
video games all right how much left one
hour
I'll see you now or it probably means
two hours but I was [ __ ] browsing
port I mean I was you [ __ ] [ __ ] head
yeah you punched me [ __ ] you [ __ ]
who punches someone I waited way too
long to play this game to die here let's
go to the church this game needs Jesus
Wow the fledging arrow flying arrow yes
punch it for good luck my friend die
[ __ ] [ __ ] at you or you want to
fight you want to rumble you want to run
on water Rumble [ __ ] gonna rock oh you
want to [ __ ] rock pop ah
oh you're running up
ah where you coming from bring out
fighting little bait oh it's all gonna
[ __ ] you up and oh are you going what
are you gonna do in there what are you
gonna do in there yeah yeah I'm gonna
[ __ ] you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh no it's a dead end here oh well
that's just too [ __ ] bad sub-clan good
[ __ ] yeah I forgot my doors open
[ __ ] car outside
this guy's really trying
what is that car doing what is that what
is happening right now
his friends or some [ __ ]
I barely touched it
all right now I'm not saying any of
these games are bad to me they are but
I'm sure a lot of people get enjoyment
out of them see Marty axes at this point
is just all about survival games that
aren't finished and I mean they're 20 15
bucks for a game that's empty
glitchy and unfinished and may never be
finished it's a promise that it will be
finished but there's no obligation to
finish it why aren't we heard about that
before steam doesn't care it's making
the money and developer doesn't care
because it's making that money and you
might think hey why do you play this
games then I'm playing them so you don't
have to be me thank you for watching as
always die awesome